once you start accomplishing your goal
the reward systems like dopamine start
kicking in but I think if people are
interested in modifying their brain for
the better at least some you know top
Contour understanding of how urgency and
focus must converge for that to happen
can be useful because I think there's a
lot of attention paid to whether or not
something feels like flow or whether or
not it's see what I call highly
desirable States or whether or not you
can eat a plant out of the ground that
will magically put your brain into a
state of plasticity and the answer is
yes such plants exist but what's missing
is the focus component if that work is
not done with a particular end goal in
mind you'll get plasticity but you'll
get plasticity in a kind of across the
board it's like learning a little bit of
nine languages all at once is not going
to make you speak coherently in any one
of them so focus is the key